thank you for your patience this evening
I Ling carpenter being the acting
returning officer at the election of a
member of parliament for tharok do
hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows Tim mark
acre UK Independence Party ten thousand
one hundred and twelve votes Jacquie
Doyle price the Conservative Party 19
thousand eight hundred and eighty votes
John can't Labour Party 19,000 535 votes
and Kevin McNamara Liberal Democrats 798
votes the turnout was sixty four point
five two percent the total rejected
ballot papers was ninety seven I do
hereby declare that Jackie door price is
duly elected member of parliament for
thorak
well here I'm again for the third time
being less the number four perfect and
marinate expected between the first time
no uncertainly let expect me to win a
second time and I didn't expect to win
tonight third time but here I am and I
have to say it is like once again an
honor and humbling to be elected for a
third time and I will continue to serve
the people work honestly and frankly and
the best of my ability as I always have
and I'd also like to pay tribute to John
who at least is still here to here the
Declaration and it says a lot about John
John's will be very close in this
campaign and that's because he is a big
beast in Thoreau politics and has given
many years of service and I know he will
continue to do and I think we should all
show our respects for that
I should now say a number of thank-yous
thank you to the counting staff who
again have had to go through a number of
recounts because there's always drama as
a third count and I should thank my
family to mark and George thank you very
much for everything you've done for me
the last few weeks and my team who've
been absolutely fantastic and serve you
being with me for more than one election
and you all know you are I'm not going
to know you but but you all being
absolutely fantastic and I won't be here
without you and we still have yet to
discover how things will play out for
the country but but hopefully I will be
doing my part to take the country
forward in due course but let's see how
that pans out thank you very much